walk him to this video playing for its
10 hmm but it's not roids 10 right it's
an IM of flesh and blood hope that some
checkers name in there International
Master Richard Wang Wang is a Canadian
it says but he's got the Turkish like so
maybe he's playing a tournament in
Turkey or something okay bye Kings
Indian and a Sri my own line okay night
a six Queenie aids what I consider to be
a good a good way to play and that and
now let's see five amongst others yeah
it's a very complicated opening leading
to a very unbalanced play the queen is
just very very sick on on Yates oh I I
try to correct it immediately yeah this
early g-force is always funny it looks
it looks very strange its amarok see
bind with G for a term it's a it's a
playable it's a player position of
course for for white hmm ok so it's
trying to really use the service g4
stuff ok
so it's a very direct way to play of
course yeah this is a typical typical
thing too for black to to allow this
capture in order to get them to get play
on the dark squares in the Kings India
this is very common I'm not sure if it
is a valid here Oh to say the least hmm
yeah this is ugly don't really uh yeah I
cannot count allow him to take it really
yeah I'm busted here well yeah I should
have firm thought a bit more about the
opening this is beyond repair already
yeah disappointing
ok let's try to at least fight a bit
take stakes and at least I've got the
dark squares fixed in the center and
maybe I'm not immediately mated h4 is
hanging so maybe he feels compelled to
take on f6 yeah okay probably all this
was and this was just too superficial or
I played ok so I'll take it finished
that's at least Bishop g5 ok but it's
this is this threatening a win I don't I
don't know if I'm able to take his night
then maybe I'm am able to defend it on
the dark squares
the good thing is that this Bishop is
not playing yeah so I just I just was
too negative about this position at
least Im how it is how i did now
preceded it so it's it's something
something that I can can actually play
unless stuff like that is working 97
what this is she would move okay I must
take it
but I can do that right or Queens you 5v
I have no choice anyway you yeah Queen
g5
Queen g5 I have Queen f7 okay whoo so
this means that probably have a pair of
rooks is going to disappear and i also
have Bishop c4
yeah the good thing is that an end game
is even good for me it's not not just
okay the thing is he's got the dead
bishop so on if everyone's if someone is
better in and in the ninth game with the
minor pieces it's black maybe it's a
draw but I'm the only one to two even
know pretend to have an edge
yeah if the H phoner oh this is cool i
really thought i'm gone in this position
and now it feels like I'm in them in
good shape
ok i create the look
osf queen of six or even cuneiform Queen
F for something to consider okay all the
check ok this is fine check this check
he's putting even more more things more
parts on dark squares okay I opened I
open this up this position hmm I didn't
didn't really appreciate this idea at
all I thought he needed to react somehow
but ok he couldn't take I thought you
would take on g4 this looks very very
very bad
if I go Queen g3 em he's got a bad [ __ ]
before I can just take but how do I win
how do I actually win the game going to
go into h1 yo yep 3 2 h 1
Scott Bishop everyone
Queen h3h one is the the key at the end
i hope i hope to have judges dis
correctly now we can maybe move the
queen this is the only only hope
no I'm promoting know like prescience is
over I really thought I was completely
busted probably I was yeah probably i
was but let's check I mean this I cannot
believe I should survive the opening 95
year plus to the comp so he probably
yeah I think he taking was better but
they came it's prolly still it still
completely completely over f4 is good f4
is plus plus 3 wow I didn't think it was
so terrible okay
hmm yeah I really meted or something
hmm yeah the side this one this is kind
of move Wow yeah I came and I mean I
already said in the in the game that I
thought I'm busted and he he just
allowed far too much and after this
there's not much not much going on I'm
just defending and strategically in my
position is somebody's here because of
the good check good Bishop here thought
you would take this this it looks it
looks very very tricky already maybe
it's lost now but a very good fighting
game you should have one after the
opening I completely I completely
misplayed that okay i don't think that
this is too bad here around here I need
to I need to improve I think I'm not
quite sure how but I need to do
something else maybe there should be six
or something this is some very very
dangerous already I mean maybe yeah man
you should be six was better anyway I
was still thinking about putting it here
and and something like that but there
should be six is better and maybe I can
go here and cook see it the typical kind
of setup in this opening I'm not I'm not
mated quickly add this is better well
that plate was just leading to probably
and lost position okay thanks for
watching